The Truth About The Surprisingly Recent Invention
Of The Tea Bag
Legend says that brewing tea dates back to
around 2737 BC, when tea leaves fell into
water being boiled for Emperor Shennong of
China.
There does not appear to be any hard evidence
of tea being discovered this way, but evidence
we do have suggests that brewing tea did indeed
likely start in China, first as part of a
medicinal elixir.
The first documented reference to this is
found during the Shang Dynasty (1600 BC to
1046 BC).
By the Qin Dynasty in the third century BC,
it had become a relatively popular drink using
just the tea (camellia sinensis), rather than
mixed with other things as seems to have been
common when used medicinally.
From the beginning until the early 20th century,
very little innovation came about in terms
of the common method of brewing tea.
This all changed in 1901.
Contrary to popular belief (and what every
single tea manufacturer I could find said
on their websites, and many-a-tea history
book and paper consulted also stated), it
was not tea merchant Thomas Sullivan who invented
the tea bag in 1908.
While he did (probably independently, given
his reported design was quite inferior to
the original) invent a tea bag that year,
he was beat out by about seven years by Roberta
C. Lawson and Mary Molaren of Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
On August 26, 1901, the two intrepid women
filed a patent (US723287) for a rather unique
(at the time) “Tea-Leaf Holder” that is
remarkably similar to the modern tea bag.
They had identified an issue with the way
tea had been commonly brewed for thousands
of years.
In their own words, the traditional method
of having to brew a whole pot at a time,
involves the use of a considerable quantity
of tea-leaves to prepare the desired supply
of tea, and the tea, if not used directly,
soon becomes stale or wanting in freshness,
and therefore unsatisfactory, and frequently
a large portion of the tea thus prepared and
not used directly has to be thrown away, thus
involving much waste and corresponding expense.
tea-bag2Thus, they invented an open-meshed
woven cotton bag, “folded over upon itself
and stitched along its side edges, forming
a pocket-like construction having a flap at
its open end… with the flap at the upper
end folded down over the top end of the pocket
and inclosed…”
A small portion of tea was then contained
inside the enclosed cotton-mesh bag and allowed
the preparer to place it “in a cup and have
water poured thereon to produce only a cup
of tea fresh for immediate use.
By this means only so much of tea-leaves is
used as is required for the single cup of
tea, and thereby a cup of fresh.
fragrant tea is prepared…”
About two years after the ladies filed their
patent, it was granted on March 24, 1903.
However, seemingly they were unsuccessful
at bringing this to market, at least on any
widespread scale that would have registered
in documented history.
This brings us to Thomas Sullivan.
Sullivan worked as a tea importer in New York
when he (supposedly) accidentally invented
tea bags in 1908.
The story goes that Sullivan began sending
small silk bags containing samples of the
various forms of tea he sold to his customers
as a way of encouraging sales.
The “accident” part is that a number of
those people who he sent the bags of tea to
decided to use the bag as something of a tea
infuser, rather than opening the bags up and
brewing the tea normally.
As with Lawson and Molaren’s aforementioned
invention, this allowed a person to make a
single cup of tea, rather than an entire pot,
and made for much more convenient clean up-
when done, simply toss the bag.
No need to clean out all the tea leaves from
the pot and strainer or infuser.
The little marketing campaign worked and orders
started rolling in, which Sullivan initially
filled via standard containers of loose-leaf
tea.
Customers who had used the bags as infusers
complained and Sullivan soon began offering
his tea once again in bags.
However, silk bags weren’t ideal for steeping
standard loose-leaf tea, due to being a little
too fine and expensive for single serve.
He, thus, replaced the silk of the original
sample bags with gauze and then further tweaked
things for better steeping by filling the
tea bags with fannings, the broken tea stalks,
and tea dust leftover from processing the
tea.
Sullivan then began heavily marketing his
little innovation and the tea bag was on its
way to becoming a household staple.
How much of this story is true is difficult
to discern.
While it does appear there was a tea merchant
named Thomas Sullivan who helped popularize
selling tea in single-serve bags (as well
as in larger tea bags for brewing whole pots),
there seems to be little in the way of documented
evidence backing up the individual bits of
the oft-repeated story.
Whatever the case, we do know that commercial
tea bags in the early days were not, on the
whole, as good as Roberta Lawson and Mary
Molaren’s original design, other than perhaps
the later addition of a string to pull the
bags out of the hot water when steeping was
complete.
You see, early bags often used glue to seal
the tea in, rather than a folded, sewn bag.
This glue then steeped along with the tea,
greatly affecting the flavor.
Various early fabrics used also often negatively
impacted the taste.
However, despite many companies early designs
being less than ideal at producing the desired
taste, convenience won out, and, partially
thanks to WWI with certain countries’ soldiers
being given tea bags as part of their rations,
the tea bag began to rise in popularity significantly
by, and then during, the 1920s.
However, while Americans relatively quickly
embraced the tea bag, the British viewed the
invention with skepticism and a bit of upturned
noses.
Shortages of the materials used to make tea
bags during World War II also helped keep
the tea bag unpopular in the UK, despite the
convenience factor and that by this time the
tea bag was mostly perfected in terms of limiting
its influence on the taste of the tea.
However, when the 1950s hit, when products
making common household tasks easier began
becoming all the rage, the tea bag saw a huge
surge in popularity, and for the first time
started gaining traction in the UK.
By the late 1950s, the tea bag had gone from
virtually unavailable in the UK to controlling
about 3% of the market, beginning its slow
and steady climb.
As of 2008, tea bags made up 96% of the tea
market in the UK, a total surprisingly more
than in the United States around that same
time, where tea bags only held about a 90%
share vs. loose-leaf tea.